[Music]
the fact that the artists can continue
to get royalties
it's a revolution it's a revolution
roger i mean like
my god
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
gary vee welcome to origin stories thank
you my friend thank you so much for
having me
this came together fast and i could not
be more thrilled we go way back i don't
even know if you know if you know this
but we go back to
i think 0.7 how about that
seems like yesterday i do know and it's
crazy that it's been that many years
already
insane and so now we find ourselves
years later
intersecting in the wonderful world of
nfts so tell the people what is your
origin story in the macro
or in the world of nft let's go blitz
let's go blitz style macro just in case
somebody doesn't know and then let's get
deep into the nft space
you know uh born born in the soviet
union
uh very fortunate to be able to be a
refugee and get out in
late in the late 70s poor
poor kid lived in queens and new jersey
parents made their american dream dad
became a stock boy in a liquor store
eventually a manager eventually bought
his own small store
which meant we saved every penny bought
nothing you know that
created a with my natural
entrepreneurial dna
and then my circumstance and environment
created incredible ambition and
scrappiness shoveling snow washing cars
selling lemonade you know very it was
just always always there
sports cards exploded in the late 80s
became a cultural phenomenon similar to
where it's at right now
um that's where i really learned my
craft doing baseball card shows
really became a seller buyer and seller
got dragged into my dad's liquor store
because now he had one
stocking shelves two bucks an hour you
know merchant son kind of 1940s 50s
style right like
immigrant life um
terrible student really good business
man as a kid
discovered the internet in 95 two
seconds in said oh my god this is going
to change my life
a year later launched an ecommerce
website for my dad's wine shop one of
the first in the country
took over operations and ran the
business from 98 to 2011
and in that uh 13-year window built my
dad's business from a 3.8 million dollar
to a 65 million dollar business
no capital infusion no vc money no
credit line just [ __ ]
grinded it innovated email
you know nft right now is just deja vu
you know all the game the games being
formulated
the winners and the losers there's some
big differences but a lot of
similarities
who were going to be the search engines
who were going to be the domain
sites where you registered your name who
we're going to be you know and then
really it culminated with youtube
i went on email and google adwords but
then youtube changed my life i started a
wine show
i learned about content became
completely obsessed with the next
revolution that i saw
which was social media i've been talking
about nft as the third revolution for
me personally there's been a lot of
technology what's that
connected those dots social media nfts
i've i've been hearing you say
that recently for me in my chemicals
95 6 just kind of internet consumer
internet
obviously was happening before 2005
6 social web 2.0 obviously was happening
before
with friendster same with nft now right
you know one of the reasons i posted a
video for me in 2010
talking about virtual goods is i've been
watching
you know i bought a theory in 16 i
bought bitcoin in 14. i've been watching
but i haven't been talking
because for me i'm not
the person that is there from day one
and constantly there
i am there from day one and then i watch
and what i look for is why i've been
talking since winter
is the moment where i'm like oh [ __ ]
it's time i mean i'm spending a ton of
time on vr
i don't think i've said a single public
thing about vr and then in
2027 when it's time i'll be very loud
the ogs will be like hey is this guy and
i'll be like hey oh geez
i'm here to respect you know i'm on this
podcast out of respect
to be honest with you i i did it with
web20 i did it with web 1.0 like
i watch and then i enter i
am definitely a consumer human more than
a technologist
so that comes with great excitement but
also
caution and that's what i'm spending
time on now
caution empathy compassion um
thoughtfulness i love this time i love
this time the
you know it's a little different for me
this time because the last two times i
was much more unknown
so i've got i have to be more careful
more thoughtfulness this time because
unfortunately well i'm flattered by this
but unfortunately when you want to be
part of a community
you know you have to be your your
platform becomes your vulnerability
you know i come in i come in very
respectful
to the people that have been grinding
and learning and building the tech
and the early artists and i'm not naive
i know that my projects and the things i
care about
will have a lot of eyes on them which
if i'm thoughtful will be good and if
i'm not thoughtful
ruins my reputation and upsets people
and so
you know i hope the community can tell
through my earliest actions over the
last six or seven weeks
that i'm trying to be very thoughtful
and i care about it this is like the
culmination of my life i've never had a
technology social media was close
i'm very human oriented i love people so
social work for me i want
to interact with people i like replying
to comments
it's not about post it and step away
it's about posting and listen
engage i i was i come from
very little so i never think i'm fancy
like humility is an incredibly
important foundation to my success it
may not come across that way i know that
i'm an aggressive communicator i'm loud
um i'm very excited which sometimes i
think people
confuse for audacity but i'm
compassionate and empathetic so i
understand why
so i'm willing to deal with negative
judgment up front
because i know the truth wins you know
so it's a very fun time but nft my god
you know the collectibility aspect wait
before we get into that what i want
to double down on what you just said is
the word respect and what i hope that i
personally can add to this equation
bringing you on to an origin story
telling that origin story telling
you know why did you enter the nft space
what i can add
following you since 07. you're loud
sometimes
right in sometimes the best of ways but
if someone catches you at just the wrong
moment just that
literal wrong moment they can have a
different impression what i personally
want to say is
i've watched you become obsessed with
multiple things
over the course of over a decade and i
can just say
my stamp for whatever that's worth for
anybody listening to this you are a
respectful person
and the empathy is outrageous and if you
caught gary at the wrong moment for
whatever reason
keep listening and you will you will all
come around in due time
that's made me emotional so thank you
that's very very nice of you to your
point for example this weekend
i'm like oh [ __ ] a lot of people
who are in for a quick buck are gonna
run into this
and buy some project because somebody
told them it's gonna go up
and when i say hey 97
of nft projects not the nft space
are very vulnerable to not being
successful investments
i believe that to be true out of history
out of knowing human
psychology i also you know and so
you can imagine if somebody sees that
they're like [ __ ] this guy like
you know you know and i'm like i get
that and i'm like no no if you look at
to your point if you look at the string
of 40 things said and that's what's
tough about a twitter or a clip and
that's why going on podcast is nice it's
like look
first of all i mean i i uh i uh
it was really fun i had a really great
moment yesterday i i bookmarked it
because i was just about to go to bed
but
there's a piece that i want to buy
because i just like it
and so there's going to be can you share
yeah it's like this little ghost i
actually don't it was that quick i was
like literally about to go to bed and so
like you know what i don't forget this
so i bookmarked it
my phone's the other room i'll grab it
but like it's just like a ghost
that was drip drawn and like colored and
i'm like this is neat and
i don't i think it's a nifty gateway and
uh trevor andrew gucci ghost maybe
it might be brother it might be actually
i got you gary i'm so deep in this space
right now i
i got you whatever you need i know you
are brother and so
i am you know i'm excited because i
think a lot of people you know i'm
trying to help people
have a very important combo which is
there's two
very interesting dynamics there's the
reason i have this on my wall
this costs a lot of money because it's a
former employee of mine and she's trying
to become an artist and i want to
support her
and so that's exciting for me and i'm
excited to meet people
and like big shout out to my friend
connor who i met you know
he's not a huge digital artist yet but
like i want to support him because i
like him
like and and there'll be people you know
i think my world's going to look like
there's people i just like and i'm
cheering for them and i want to support
now i will never tweet this is a great
investment
you should because if i don't believe
that why would i do that to him myself
or her myself
but there's gonna be people who want to
support their art because i like them
then there's gonna be things like the
ghost i'm not even sure who's behind it
back to your point i think you're
probably right now that my brain's
thinking but like
that i just liked i just weirdly like
ghosts like in general like
i used to draw it a lot pac-man was huge
for me as a kid so that kind of ghost
um and i'll do that and then there's
gonna be a ton i do i'm a baseball card
collector i'm a comic book collector i'm
a toy collector
by nature nfts are incredibly
interesting to me
the street fighter thing's really cool i
want to buy blanca because i'm
undefeated with blanca and street
fighter for super nintendo
but i also didn't buy it right away
because i do think it and
you know they were going to go up very
quickly on wax and then i'll buy it when
when it comes down i don't i don't see
that as again as an investment
i'm going to put that on the flip side
you know when i look at pepe as a first
play in bitcoin right truly
nft on bitcoin not ethereum yeah as a
collector i'm like ooh that has a real
shot
but but what's funny is when i use my
brain and my heart where i go is to
crypto punks
because i'm like okay that's first
aetherium but [ __ ] i really love these
[ __ ] this is nintendo 8-bit
these really speak to me
you know ethereum you know obviously
there's a lot of conversations around
scalability
you know i'm spending all this time
thinking about myself of wrapping coins
because all who the hell knows which
blockchain is going to win and so i'm
just doing all this education
right um but i look at crypto punks
very different than i look at street
fighter wax
street fighter wax is singular i need
blanca because i need to show my friends
who i beat a thousand times a blank and
everybody would get upset because i
figured out a way to play with him
that's a personal thing crypto punk says
holy [ __ ] this thing could really be an
investment
if i'm as right as i think i am about
nfts this
project has a real shot and those would
be things that over time i'll put on the
record be like this is what i believe in
so there's a lot of conversations
to be had but i appreciate you saying
that and i'm excited to earn
my keep i don't come in here i'm
fascinated by people that
do well somewhere else and think that
all of a sudden means that they should
be look you know to me i'm starting from
the bottom
in this community and i want to do all
the right things i also
and i did this in sports cards i also
remind people look there's a part of me
that likes to collect and support and
there's a part of me that likes to trade
it is my
you know you know i told a lot of sports
car people like look
because they were mad they're like you
shouldn't buy and sell like look i
respect that
but are you really the human that gets
to decide what i can do
right you know like i don't know if
you're paying attention but
you know open c exists not for
collecting it's not like a collecting
wall
like these things exist and so and it's
a very delicate conversation right
one of the reasons so many artists are
not going to be quote unquote starving
is because of a secondary market and
that's true what is
remarkable i mean literally if you can
see this they're starting to form
getting a couple little goosebumps here
you know um
the fact that the artist can continue to
get royalties
it's a revolution it's a revolution
roger i mean like
my god you know i could super understand
the artists of the past
who would be super sad they would make a
painting the gallery they had a deal on
would pay them a certain amount
and they'd wake up 11 years later and
things selling for 11 million dollars
and they got 8 000.
yep i mean my god
you know no matter how no matter how
many open seat transactions there are
and beyond
it's always that 10-ish percent that's
going back to the creator
i can't get over it i don't know what
else to tell you like to me this is the
greatest thing so
yeah anyway to to origin story like that
was who i was as an entrepreneur i did
really well invest in a lot of companies
built a large marketing company
have built a big content platform
i this is the scariest of them all i'm
asking myself questions of like
oh is this it like is this gonna be the
one was this all built you know
for example you i know you pay attention
everything
you go my my team is finding all these
videos of me doodling
i've never shared that part of me
because i've never wanted to
you know i can't you know i'm going to
poke around at that like gary b
gary b is is where it's at it just is i
can't believe that something that a lot
of when i've been
so i posted four or five of my doodles
and
i can't believe it like
i've always thought of myself far more
creative than i've ever showed the world
it's actually similar to when i was the
wine guy and then i started talking
about business and a lot of people were
like
stay in your lane wine boy don't talk
about business and i was like my god
i've always been a businessman
what's so incredible about minting and
technology and
vectoring and digital art and i think
there's gonna be millions of people who
actually have artistic
oomph who are gonna dabble in a way that
they never thought they could
and i think that's beautiful it's gonna
be an artistic revolution now
now i think a lot of people gonna
misstep it because there's gonna be so
much conversation around
finances when people start seeing wow
or people or you know like they're gonna
see things that are gonna confuse people
just for the community that's listening
this is what always happens
there's an art renaissance and then
comes commerce
and it gets a little blurry for a little
bit and just staying true to who you are
during this time is imperative
because i do think it's going to be a
little bumpy here for 24 to 36 months as
it settles
similar to icos i think raj you know if
you go back 40 years ago
you had that kind of spike and then you
had all these coins right
and it took market a little bit to level
out kind of to where we are now
i don't think it will take four years
because i think we've learned from that
at least some people and things are so
compressed these days that that may be
a one-year shakeout period i think
that's right and i think that it's
important to not get overly emotional
about convincing
i think you know i think that's where a
lot of people are going to get caught
the og's trying to convince
yes i think i i say don't convince
have conviction it's a great it's a
great quote
so gary i have a bit of a thesis here
maybe i'll present it to you see what
you think
i think two categories of art is win um
i always i hate to be a cold language
like that because
here for the art as well i kind of share
with you the the traitor philosophy as
well as the empathy and just the love
philosophy so i appreciate you saying
that
i think two categories win i think
artists let's say the top
i don't know 25 loosely that are
identified as blue chip artists i think
they'll have
a consistent shelf life forever and ever
and i think the second category what i
would encourage
any artist that doesn't know or gets a
bit confused to focus on
i think the niche artist who does a
great job of to your point having
conviction
and focusing on his or her community
even if it's small to mid-size
i think we'll have that longevity as
well what do you think about that
i think that's right i think that's
right i think um
i think there's a lot i think both of
those play out exactly
to your point i think that um
i also think it's the it's the artist
that genuinely cares about their
community
and i think this is an important thing
to talk about there are a lot of artists
who don't and that's okay i don't judge
that
i just think that to build an economy
around an art you know everyone's like
oh this is great
i now the artist don't have to rely on
an agent
or the gallery what the artist has to
understand when they take on that
responsibility
is just making the art is
one of it's the variable but it's only
one of them i remind people that art
is in the eye of the beholder there's a
subjectiveness that is incredible
around this and actually cultivating a
community
of people that care about you like
matters and there's a million ways to do
it
you know banksy does it different than i
the reason people care about me is i
engage
right you know like for real like you
know and so
i think that that will be interesting
who's going to actually
truly care about the their early
their early supporters you know i've
watched a lot of artists talk about like
being og and then even in three weeks
have watched them be less so
less about their original community than
the new fancy people that are talking to
them
yeah you're right you know that's just
real talk so like they were razzing and
then three weeks later they're doing the
behavior
of what they were razzing because now
they have the opportunity to yeah
i think that's the pitfall right there
they get too caught up in the mania
you know the that base that strong
foundation may not be there for you when
the mania when the mania dies down
and i think the other thing back to the
you know be nice on the way up because
people catch you on the way down i think
the other thing people have to be
empathetic to is supply and demand
just because you're first doesn't mean
your best just because you're first
doesn't mean
you made something that captures
people's imagination
and so you know just realizing that this
is going to be a floodgate you know
one of the great things of the old world
was limited people got into galleries
one of the terrible things of the old
world is that limited people got into
the galleries
you know i look at this like influencer
marketing actually
you know everybody can now be an
influencer
and i think everybody now will have an
opportunity to play out
some of their ambitions in art you know
the art world said jackson pollock was
not art
until they did this always happens this
is history
so what people have to be prepared for
is actual supply and demand there's
going to be more supply
over the next six months in nft projects
than anybody on this call
listening or watching me and you
included can comprehend 100 agree
literally everybody
and most of it 98 of it is gonna be
short-term transactions
which creates a very interesting and
scary bubble scenario
and so back to convincing and conviction
the ogs
the people that are really about it the
people that are here for you know for me
what shook me is like oh [ __ ] this is
something i want to be a part of
forever just like social media right
you did you did your back work you saw
it and now you're here
correct i spent the fourth quarter
reading and watching i even
even the thing that i most zeroed in on
them punks i didn't act on which i wish
i did
you know it when i just come a long way
they moved very fast there before i
really got my hands around some
um but i really wanted to do my homework
i needed to understand erc
20 versus 721 like i needed to i needed
to be able to go on a podcast like this
and not seem out of place or like you're
seeing with certain influencers and
artists i didn't want to do a project so
fast
where you didn't where i didn't know all
the like i didn't know about all the
metadata at first
i needed to understand for myself what
would happen
if a blockchain lost long term could i
wrap
the tokens like i don't even know what
the term rap meant right you know
six months ago you know i knew the macro
thesis
i knew virtual currency was real for a
long long time hence
i'll be bringing out those videos to
make sure everyone knows
but you know i understood a closed
ecosystem of a skin in a video game i
understood a closed
ecosystem of a madden card this brings
this now to everything and
by the way we're talking about a very
narrow use of the blockchain and nfts
i mean this is incredible where this is
actually going
from a ledger at scale to the
digitalization of everything i mean we
are in
prehistoric days of this yes
gary to play a game i know i know you
love questions i know you thrive
in questions and so i did something
called the lightning round wanted to
bring it in a little bit earlier
and start hitting you with some rapid
fire i have some topics and i have some
questions
from the people you ready for them
please all right
the first question i think everyone
wants to know was the first time you
you saw the word nft the concept nft the
very first
mention that captivated you captivated
me or the mention
let's go mention first captivated second
mentions a while
like you know i i remember thinking like
what's fungi like we're talking years
now
right you know again
a big shout out to aaron battalion who's
an incredible
uh cto uh co-founder of living social
which was a groupon competitor back in
the day in 2016-17
range in a hotel room in austin texas he
broke down ethereum for me
and i understood i'm like okay this is
like in my most basic form of like okay
bitcoin is this thing
ethereum feels like developers will
build on top of it like i thought api
i thought platform it got my brain
thinking differently
and so very quickly after that i already
kind of like started hearing of
nft the time it really caught my
attention was probably about
march of last year like something
kind of caught my attention i
i was getting big you know i was
obviously deep in the sports card world
cove hidden i was scaring shitless to
make sure my companies were okay
and i just needed like 30 minutes you
know occasionally just to like
learn and be creative and that's where i
kind of like
stumbled on maybe maybe
you know i don't want to make it up so i
just kind of like i definitely knew
about the garbage pail kids wax thing
um those are the first things i found
too interesting
because that was you know obviously very
much because i was steep into what's
going on
um you know but i but that one
that was interesting to me because i'm
like what's wax versus a theory you know
as i go different blockchains punks hit
my radar
you know lightly and you know i'd seen
some tweets
you know i also knew the original
developers from back like the web 2.0
days i knew the names
when it really caught me was this fall
like september october like
crypto punks are is an important project
and that led me down nft whoa
this is whoa whoa this is whoa but i was
like in
q4 mode budgeting you know i'm an
operator people forget that i'm not
actually quote-unquote garyvee i'm like
running a really big business
so i was trying to set up still
navigating the waters covered losing
clients what's going on
offices and then i was able to use
the holidays like december january like
the last week december 1st
january to dig even deeper the true true
explosion
yeah i was like okay this is like [ __ ]
me i need to buy some crypto punks
you know art blocks what's this and like
hash mask so there's like oh this is
what open sea i was like
this is really happening and then i hit
up my homie kevin rose
former you know founder of dig.com and
he's always on and he's like i'm already
in this then we started yapping
and the juices are battalion yeah
my brother and like just whoa this is
feeling like 15 you know this is feeling
like 2005
6. this is feeling like 95.
um oh my god this is real real real real
what's your first purchase my first
purchase was a
single crypto punk in
january then i bought four hash masks
randomly just
like play and then i bought a sorer
bombape so that was my first little
burst of like three or four
purchases all right let's go rapid fire
here topics
number one new jersey i gotta give the
shout out to my wife
marissa from new jersey seeing you in
new jersey what do you think new jersey
what do i what's my like word
association first word association
the grind the grind love it
what's the top selling nft concept one
year from today crypto punks
and that segues us right into crypto
punks word association
the project what's up project jets
my escapism tom brady
he pisses me off dirt
dirt dirt oh god you know me well
um honest
and i want to break that one down
because i have a i have so much
compassion for
who i think listens to this podcast so
many of you are from the dirt of nft
and my admiration for that is at the
highest levels
i think that people that come from the
most humble places
are the people i admire the most
genuinely i believe in the process
like i said the jets are my escapism
because it's my my
journey to try to acquire i don't wanna
everyone's like he's obsessed with
owning the jets they're wrong i'm
obsessed with trying to buy the jets the
process
the process i've enjoyed the last 12
weeks
many good things i think will happen to
me in this space none of which
will ever compare to these moments the
first this is my first
podcast that i'm really talking about it
the
the the second i'm like oh i don't have
to be scared anymore
if ethereum doesn't win because i think
this rap thing can help
learning right the late staying up at
midnight being like
there was a bitcoin project pepe before
punks like those moments are everything
to me
big deal everything everything i love it
like the the chats on twitter meeting
the people
like having the combos putting out a
tweet of last night of like what podcast
canceling a pretty important meeting to
do this with you right now because i
just met
because i need it you know i want it i
love it i love it
let's go the opposite let's go clouds
clouds
clouds um when i think about clouds i'll
think about macro strategy i refer to
clouds as like
what why like what and so i think macro
strategies when i think clouds
smurfs an ip i'd love to
i grew up on smurfs i like that cartoon
you
own that ip bring them into the nft
space well that's you know it's so funny
i've talked there's a trillion you know
this is
why excuse me why this is such a um
huge huge place for me i've been talking
about nostalgic ip
at nausea for the last seven years of my
content the manifestation of that in
this space
well you know what makes me sad so many
of these incredible things
scooby-doo hannah barbara fraggle rock
happy days [ __ ] that i really love like
70s and 80s pop culture
i know in my soul 85 they're going to go
sloppy into this space and ruin their
brand
let me phrase dent their brand instead
of exploding it
hence why i talk about being thoughtful
yeah those who get this right then the
nostalgic brands who get this right are
just
going to jupiter jupiter
yard sales
the thrill of the hunt ufc
um incredibly underrated sport even
though it's so hot
100 agree the influencer who is not
currently in or exploring nfts who you
believe
should be in nfts the rock
nice good one and now gary it's the
people's lightning round
farmed out ten questions gonna throw
them at you rapid fire them or dive into
them if you like
number one shout out zuk d if the jets
win the super bowl what current artist
would you
gary vee commission to make a one-of-one
of the moment
i would do a humongous search
and speak to the most authentic artist
that is
really passionate about the jets like
can really ask my questions and also has
an aesthetic style
that i subjectively thought was epic
that survey would be so key rooting out
who is the real jets fan
yeah i think it would be such a moment
and if i was like for some reason
associated with being able to be the
project it would take a lot of
thoughtfulness like a micro version of
what i've been doing for the last six
months
number two shout out sutton s when are
you going to change your profile picture
to a crypto punk
when i buy a couple more crypto punks
that i really want you know it's really
it's a
that's just an authentic answer right
like i really want to score one or two
more things
because i'm scared i'm also honestly
it's actually not an authentic answer
it's a 37 i'm ver i i
am i am petrified to affect the market
i live this in sports cards i remember
i'm not i'm very worried if that happens
it's funny even this podcast i'm giving
you off i don't know how to not answer
the question
i'm not naive that this is going to be
listened to and like some people like oh
because i'm being very candorous i also
don't think i'm always right
i also think who the [ __ ] am i but i
also am aware
that some people which is why i'm like
do your own homework i understand i have
a nice track record
i do have a nice track record i do
believe in my picking ability
but i've but i picked yobongo and
thought it was gonna be the biggest
startup of all time and it failed so
i think that um i don't know when i also
think that what i'll probably end up
doing
if it's okay with the crypto punks
community i'll have to probably ask the
founders
i kind of want to like get some
one who's talented enough to make their
own custom version of me wearing
like a a green a purple cap or a green
cap you know like
you know so i don't know when i'm gonna
do it but i do think it will happen
at some point i like that tj shout out
tj the real question is do you own a
crypto cube
if not when do you plan to get one i
don't
um i don't know when i plan to get one
but i want to get
i want to do more community uh you know
more
uh education on it you know what i mean
like what i'm doing is i'm not doing
anything like the amount of i have smart
friends
and i have people that are being very
generous with their intellect and
knowledge
i just don't rush into things yeah smart
man shout out new view
investor gary how do you evaluate an nft
what is your criteria
my in uh the underlying information
supply and demand who's behind it
what do i know about them do i think
they're a good i look i think of it as
jockeys and horses
you know the underlining data the
subjectiveness and my
ability on the creative part
that's the horse the jockey is who's the
human behind this do they understand how
to cultivate
a community in perpetuity or are they
just trying to do something for a quick
win
right so those are the two big criterias
shout out to wheel nfts with a physical
counterpart does a physical devalue the
nft or does it not matter
my intuition is that it enhances
i think it broadens people's intrigue
i think it's another data point to make
it interesting
i don't know where the community sits on
this if they think that eliminates its
purity
i could see a path to that i also don't
think anybody gets to make the rules and
i think that people that just want to do
the nft are right for them and
themselves and i think the people that
want to do the physical counterpart are
right for them and themselves
yeah i think that one of the bigger
issues right now in this space is the
physical custody no one knows how that's
going to play out right
it once once that nft with the physical
counterpart is sold the physical is
distributed
and then that nft is reposted on a
secondary sales site
do you get the physical do you not what
condition is it in someone open i think
that's one of the bigger issues i
imagine someone's going to step in and
take care of that
it's funny for me my intuition is that
they should be separated
immediately that the nft that's what's
amazing about the blockchain
and the ledger it's like so incredible
it is and i think
let the let the real world do its real
world thing you're not gonna ever be
able to attach it you've already created
a vulnerability if you think you're
gonna attach it because of condition
providence like what really happened
right i think it's a nice to have
it's an added value it isn't the thing
right
it's how my stomach thinks of it yeah i
think they either it's either that and
that's probably most cases and i imagine
there's a service that comes out that
does take custody
and and work tile it and it just sits
somewhere exactly i think that's i think
that's right
shout out joel miyazawa what is your
biggest pain point with nfts
you know what's so funny my brain went
here right away it's my
knowledge that it's going to get mucky
here
how this plays out i know how this plays
out and i remember
the hurt feelings of people i loved
in web 2.0 when it started crossing the
chasm of being commercialized
and the purity of we're going to change
the world
mixing with monies and this one is much
more transactional than that was
yes um my biggest difficulty
is knowing that there's gonna be a lot
of emotion
a lot of money lost a lot of short-term
thinking
a lot of bad characters a lot of people
becoming miffed of the overall space
because they'll see
somebody that they grew up with turn
into in their mind somebody who's
selling out
even though that person is just trying
to do something
you know that's good for their family
there's just there's gonna be emotions
and i know that
and so because i know that it's like
this is why i'm
i think i'm speaking the way i am to
everybody which is like hey be prepared
it's okay it's okay like
let go of commencing lean into
conviction tell
do it your way because you'll win in the
end you will win in the end
you build a meaningful project that has
real community
you might get outsold by somebody who's
a better self-promoter
but let's talk about what it looks like
in nine years and that's what i always
play for
that's the biggest deal is ignoring the
person who's out selling you now
that because that's it's so easy to look
at that it just so
and and having the humility to not
impose your way of seeing this
on everybody yes people people
you know it's like it's important
because it's what happens to people that
fall in love with a band that gets big
they start hating them
that's right but you didn't get to
control you know you don't get to
control what the band's doing
you get to control how you enjoy it
you're in charge of that
that's right i knew about them first
right it's that that whole thing which
is gonna happen which is gonna happen a
lot right now
yeah no question shout out to bill ellis
fabulous artist by the way how do we
guarantee the longevity of the nft space
it's been guaranteed nice good answer
good answer also bill ellis
okay it's real let me just triple down
in that
yeah it's you know
google is a very big search engine
i was there when everybody was fighting
it out yahoo dog pile
you know ash jeeves like all these sg's
good reference
you know and a lot of them were worth a
lot of money on paper and they went to
zero
search engines are here yep nft
collectibles arts and all the music and
all the beautiful things that are coming
will be here for everyone's rest of
their life
will there is there a concern that all
this
gold rush will hurt the brand to the
overall market
of course will that not matter in the
end
of course people thought the internet
was a fad when the stock market
collapsed
in april of 2000 and everyone dismissed
the internet that's when i
tripled down on the internet and changed
my life do i think there'll be a crash
of things that are selling for a lot of
money right now i do
i really do but do i think that that
eliminates the market no i do not
yeah it's inevitable but i like your
initia that initial answer of
it's already been guaranteed uh also
also a question from bill ellis when are
you gary vee going to drink whiskey with
me and roger
i'm open to it i actually you know i'm i
am still
through and through a wine man and when
my whiskey friends bring it out but i am
i am far from scared of having a good
whiskey or a good bourbon or
you know i and i've you know don't
forget my family owns a liquor store
i've got some stuff
i've got some stuff i got some papi i've
got some stuff i've got some japanese
stuff i've got some stuff
so i'm in for it i'm in for it nice
shout out danette danette were you
bitter 65 gary in the blou
auction i was not i saw that that was
not me
and i'm so happy for blou i really am
and talk to him a bunch before
the uh process uh but i was not
shout out nicholas costa where do you
source your information
in the nft space who are you following
it's funny what a great question i'm
very
um i'm just following a lot of voices i
get into rabbit holes
speaking a lot to friends that i really
know
like scott belski kevin rose
lazaro talk to those kind of character a
little bit more
outside of it right then i follow and
listen to you maddie
down in australia dcl blogger shout out
huge fan um you know
uh there so you know there's there's
you know you know jeff holgram
holberg you know has been somebody i've
spent a lot of time with
you know um uh trying to think
because i want to make sure emmanuel who
was that coca-cola has been
very involved in so rare matt at larva
was very gracious and i was able to
speak to kevin rose has been a big
factor because he's so
truly authentically a learner too
and i went through that with him he's
been big for me and just
continue to add people to conversations
um uh donny
over bitsky he was very gracious with
several
hours of time bitsky's picking up some
heat right now
you know um so
you know i'm you know people was very
gracious and you know
his journey um um
and just a lot of people on dm little
tidbits i also
i also am a very interesting learner i
don't like taking anybody's points of
view
i like listening to them you know
um and then kind of looking at
things you know mike novogratz you know
somebody i've spent some time
talking to like a lot of a lot of people
but i'm in this i'm a very funny
character
i take everything with a grain of salt
because i'm aware that people have
subconscious subconscious agendas
it's very true which i don't blame
you know so i try to be thoughtful i i
watch what people react to
you know i watch every comment on the
artifact drop
like i want i read people more than
experts
i read you know i try to get educated
gary that's why i love this so much i
love seeing you dive into nfts because
i've seen you dive publicly into other
things before
and i've seen your process before and
i've seen you get your hands dirty
before
i see you go out there and like when it
came time
right when that came time and when the
next book when the next book came time
i've seen you get out there and then
i've seen you pull back
and and go through this process that's
as old as time
i love that our paths intersected in
this space
and see you do it here it's really it's
really meaningful to me separately
and i just think that everyone listening
to this in nfts
should be really excited that you're
doing it i appreciate that i
like being good for communities and i
know how to do it
and i think when you have a big
microphone like i do which i've earned
so there'd be no confusion no doubt um
i'm gonna be very careful with it
incredibly and
i will make micro missteps because we
all do
but i but i think when you have a
platform those get compounded so i'm
petrified to do so
and i just really enjoy this community
so much so much
and look i mean let's call a spade a
spade there is the art combo
there is a heavy layer of collectibility
in this
a lot of the tokens are very grounded in
video game
sports card comic book culture something
that i feel
deeply comfortable in deeply
you know i've never collected art and
flipped it i've only supported art
which is awesome actually because i
think that's going to be good for me in
this space
but boy do i like buying an athlete you
know nba top shop
yes i think it's an incredible project
for a million reasons
i also think it's an incredibly
interesting project because i think a
lot of people can lose a lot of money
not because top shots doing anything
wrong rolehome is incredibly thoughtful
flow i i think it's amazing it's that
those are more like sports cards
they'll be the next one in the next year
and the next year and i know what kevin
garnett
and chris paul and tim duncan and
patrick ewing rookie cards go for
there's not a sustainability to top shot
long term
and so i'm very concerned of how big
that crash will be
on it especially because it's by far the
biggest project for the normal consumer
does that hurt quote unquote the space
it may
yeah this is why we have to educate and
say things like this i'm a macro master
fan
a top shot i think it's so cool
basketball the best culture
yeah but i'm also a monster fan of
sports cards but i'm out there saying
all the time that if you buy rookies and
not lebron and jordan
yeah you're gonna somebody's gonna be
held with the bag are you gonna get hurt
and look look at the junk wax there
right what's happening right now in top
shots right now
now they're starting to say anyone who
reserves will get it well that's a
supply faucet that's been turned on
but even if you go to the original stuff
terry rozier can't
maintain long-term value right right
tyler hero can't
they have to become a top 25 player of
all time
and i'm eligible i bring up hiro and
rogers guys that i
admire tremendously who at this point
i'm pretty convinced they're not going
to be one of the 25 to 50 best players
of all time
and i tell people to go look at vince
carter or dirk novitskiy rookie cards
and and then look at current player
rookie cards who are four times more
expensive
on supply and demand and i say put that
into top shot
you need to be careful don't forget
there's a bunch of ethereum and bitcoin
trillionaires
right who are diversifying
which creates economic dynamics so it's
just a time to be thoughtful
and a time to focus on your conviction
i'm excited to be a part of it i thank
you for your
your time man gary it's been an absolute
absolute pleasure today
uh let's let's grab that glass of whisk
with bill ella sometime send me a dm
let's do that
i will absolutely absolutely talk to you
bye-bye bye
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon